[Musique]
je raconterai aujourd'hui une aventure
qui m'est arrivé à moi même c'est à dire
que j'y attache une importance
particulière
c'est humain n'est ce pas un bluff enfin
quand des images je me comprends
[Musique]
il ya quelques jours j'étais assise à
cette même place
je faisais paisiblement ma toilette
toute la famille était là car il faisait
un temps à ne pas mettre un paysan
dehors
moi qui avais premiers automates de les
pinces et aujourd'hui trois jours qu'il
pleut on n'a jamais vu ça non pas depuis
la dernière fois vous dites en journée
pour finir et vous vous amusiez petit
shot anouma montrant jouer encore à la
poupée
si vous préférez ou va jouer à qui son
vol bisontin poisson folle tu as perdu
et valhalla et mieux d'apprendre à
coudre ou d'écrire votre oncle alfred au
toit le chat mêle toi de tes affaires
je trouve les petites si amusante tant
qu'il y aura des filles
nous en reparlerons vous savez
parfaitement que je ne peux pas avoir de
file de garçons non plus d'ailleurs
n'essayez pas de me vexer quoi qu'il en
soit je te conseille de ne pas te faire
remarquer d'abord si peu c'est de ta
faute
ils n'arrêtent pas de faire sa toilette
je fais ma toilette parce que je suis
propre si ça fait pleuvoir ce n'est pas
ma faute c'est une loi de la nature
à part ça on se demande à quoi tu sers
des souris trop de la cave au grenier
pendant ce temps tu te prélassent moi
c'est la nuit que je travaille pendant
que vous vous prélassez faut toujours il
est le dernier mot c'est l'arrêt
vineberg
à la fin de l'après-midi en pleuvait de
plus en plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
traire les vaches
prenez garde de ne rien casser fait
surtout attention à sa plate faïence
il a plus de 100 ans savait combien de
temps un plat de faïence
si on jouait un voleur et aux gens dont
tu veux durant gendarmes et voleurs
non c'est le voleur qui poursuivra le
gendarme on sait bien son tour en valeur
les tuchanais ne courez donc pas comme
ça vous allez casser quelque chose
j'avais oublié de pour présenter je me
nomme en effet alphonse vous me direz
drôle de nom pour un achat ce sont les
petites qui m'ont baptisé alphonse avec
les enfants il ne faut jamais cherché à
comprendre
je vous avais prévenu on va ramasser les
morceaux et jeté ensuite on est une
réelle place sur le mur au le places
payantes
un père qui avait plus de cent ans voilà
en 100 morceaux
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes deux ati la défense de jouer
et enfin sec mais je n'ai pas assez haut
il faudrait une punition terrible j'ai
trouvé demain s'il fait beau ne comptez
pas vous promenez vous irez voir la
tante mélina j'ai dit demain s'il fait
beau ou j'irai voir attentes médina ils
n'apporteraient pourtant figure oui il
m'en reste humble de l'année dernière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le vent a balayé les nuages
demain les petites auront un temps
superbe pour aller voir leurs tentes
mélina je voudrais pas être à leur place
talent bien mérité
c'est que la tante mélina était une très
vieille et très méchant de femmes avec
une bouche sans dents et un menton plat
de barbe
quand les petites filles aller la voir
dans son village elle ne se lassait pas
de les embrasser ceux qui n'étaient pas
très agréables à cause de la barbe
[Musique]
la tante may line a trouvé que ces deux
petites nièces lui ressemblait beaucoup
et affirmé qu'elle serait plus tard ses
deux fidèles portrait ce qui est
effrayant a pensé pour un plat casser le
châtiment est lourd
j'aurais dû dire que c'était moi qui
avait cassé le plat moi je n'ai pas de
tente mélina du moins à ma connaissance
je sais que j'ai une idée toujours des
idées de monsieur alphonse de bien on
n'ira pas de leurs attentes
j'ai entendu ce qu'ont dit les parents
qu'on partira s'il faisait beau
alors halte ans n'a qu'à passer sa patte
derrière son oreille il pleuvra demain
il peut de temps de nina qui ferait ça
pour nous un fond bon je ferais bien
plus difficile je me mis donc derechef à
l'oeuvre les autres animaux n'étaient
pas contents ils savaient que je pouvais
faire la pluie et le beau temps mais
préférer le beau temps le chien vous
lui-même m'arrêter je vis avec le chien
dans un état de guerre froide
bref free an passé plus de 50 fois ma
patte derrière mon oreille j'étais
tranquille pour le lendemain
on ne peut pas durer a sûrement se
dégager en attendant le sens des gages à
les mettre vos robes du dimanche et un
autre ruban dans les cheveux pour aller
voir la tante may line là
[Applaudissements]
mais le temps me se dégagea pas bien sûr
[Musique]
puisque le temps ne se dégage pas
enlever vos rendez-vous ruban vous
dirais que dommages et la tante may line
a mais je leur mis aussitôt à passer ma
patte d'ef lire mon oreille est il plus
encore le lendemain et les jours
suivants et dieu sait combien de temps
cela aurait pu durer
[Musique]
pourquoi veux tu me parlais de hors jeu
ne soit pas que le shaq nous entende
c'est vrai avec cette bête on n'est plus
chez soi les jours qu'il pleut sans
discontinuer tout pourri je ne peux plus
travailler et les petites ne peuvent pas
aller voir leurs tentes c'est la faute
du sein il passe tous les soirs sa patte
derrière son oreille
tu n'as qu'à le lien interdit cela passe
en cachette du cd il a fait qu'à sa tête
je prends une décision plus radicale
c'est toi qui commandent mon ami le
chercher une pierre et un sac
oui
[Musique]
toi parapluie
vous avez l'air ennuyé maman ne
m'appelle pas maman j pas ta mère
[Musique]
voilà une pierre et un sac et qu'est ce
que vous allez en faire
c'est une surprise regarde je mets
d'abord la pierre d'un sac approchait
tu verras mieux ya troppo tu as vu oui
il pleut toujours mais je suis désolé
vous êtes faut que je vous prends je
comprends qu'on ne veut plus d'un chat
qui fait pleuvoir tout le temps et
puisque tu aimes tant look ça qu'ils
veulent avoir tout un sou dans 5 minutes
qui fera sa toilette au fond de la
rivière
je sais que ça je parie que c'est la
cornette qui est en train de faire sont
vos jeux les vues il ya une heure il
commençait à souffrir voulu donner un
coup de main quand tu ne fais rien pour
vos parents de me jeter à l'eau parce
que je fais que le voir depuis journée
dit on va vivre et non vos parents se
douteront bien que je ne me suis pas
évadé tout seul ils sont capables de
vous envoyer six mois chez votre tante
may line or les maisons des deux pays
mais c'est pas le moment de pleurer j'ai
volontairement n'ont pas les moyens de
désigner un fonds 72,5
on devrait trouver une meilleure
solution il faudrait réfléchir demander
conseil on a même si vos parents sont en
train d'aider la cornette avait alors
demandé à un ami
tout est sur le pas de la porte
oui tu te sens pas l'âme si on ne trouve
pas une idée vous voyez notre ami pour
la dernière fois au mieux bon débarras
si tu penses vraiment statut n'a rien à
faire ici et bien mon avis aucun
sentiment de solidarité redirai
absolument un homme que j'ai une idée je
vais faire un discours aux parents
contre la peine de mort je leur
montrerai que lorsqu'on tue un chat un
chat ou point cochons par exemple eh
bien on commet un aussi grand crime que
s'ils ont tué un homme papa avoir deux
discours
j'ai 19 ans assez peu pour une fille
mais c'est beaucoup pour un cheval volet
plus pour longtemps
tant qu'à finir mes jours bientôt autant
que morale utile
alphonse au contraire est encore jeune
il a son avenir de chat devant lui veut
prendre sa place bartok m'a tuer le
meilleur des investisseurs si j'ai la
chance de ne pas mourir aujourd'hui je
n'oublierai jamais ta proposition mais
je crains que si tu prends ma place dans
le sac où je suis moi même déjà à
l'étroit
les parents ne s'en aperçoive tu es un
peu plus gros que moi tu sais je n'avais
pas pensé à ça j'ai une meilleure idée
il n'y a qu'à mettre une bûche dans le
sac à la place d'alphonse les parents
s'apercevront vite que dans le sac
rien ne bouge ne respirent ni me parlait
mais tu n'es pas obligé de parler après
tout tu es un chat or attendez je crois
que j'ai trouvé je reviens pendant ce
temps mettez une bûche dans le sac
je voudrais seulement te demander un
service
maintenant que l'accord n'est qui nous a
fait un joli vos faits noyé ce maudit
chatte
on pourrait peut-être lui faire grâce en
l'honneur du bo nous a pas le rapport
petite souris
comment te sens-tu dans ce ca je vous
remercie
as tu compris ce qu a dit shah pas un
mot je vais t'expliquer à nouveau donc
le chat t'attraper vivante et on échange
de la vie sauve
ils te demandent un service étant
fermées dans ce sac ça j'ai compris
remue un peu pour voir ce que ça donne
très bien mais où comme eric champ trop
d'accord avec la bûche qui fait le poids
et toi qui met de l'animation on
jurerait qu'elles font c'est comme ça
non et puis de seulement 2 par le tueur
une voie impossible
alors qu'est-ce qui n'osent pas si mon
père va jeter le sac dans la rivière où
là je ne suis plus la cote mais la
rivière n'est pas à côté d'ici papa y
arrives tu fais un petit trou dans le
sac et jusqu'à la dernière seconde
tu te laisse glisser par terre c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire maintenant
qu'est plus le choix tais toi voilà papa
bonjour papa ça papa avoue ne sangloter
pas pourquoi sans doute aurions-nous
parce que je vais noyer chat nous sommes
tous mortels et chacun pour soi je vois
que tu as pris fin dans l'école des
petites filles et attachant ni fleurs ni
couronnes ils remuent mais ils ne
daignent pas répondre il est fixé
mettez-vous à sa place moi je n'y tiens
pas allons donc
[Musique]
alors on est débarrassé du chat oui oui
c'est trop beau pour être vrai non il
faut le cacher on te portera à manger la
nuit
le lendemain il fit un temps superbe mon
sacrifice avait apaisé la colère des
parents ils renoncèrent à envoyer les
petites chez leur tante mais il fit beau
aussi le surlendemain et ainsi de suite
un mois qu'il fait beau on n'a jamais vu
ça n'ont pas pu la dernière fois
décidément la mort de ce pauvre alphonse
pour les aguerrir attriste
les enfants n'ont pas de coeur ouais il
m'arrive de le regretter alphonse il
avait de la conversation m étais pas de
souris mais ça faisait respecter c'est
vrai si c'était à refaire
moi je ne suis pas si sûr que le chat
soit mort qu'est-ce qui a dit ça moi il
me semble bien l'avoir aperçu mais
qu'est ce que tu racontes occupe toi
donc plutôt de ses poules beaucoup moi
ce que j'en ai vu
quelle petite cervelle à ce coq petite
cervelle mais bonneville
oui vous pourrez le manger pour le 14
juillet
et pour le 14 juillet le coq fut manger
rôti
mais il ne pleuvait toujours pas
[Musique]
encore une semaine et tout sera grillé
salade sont jaunes comme des coins et
les recoins vertes comme les salades
c'est votre faute petite saute je vous
n'aviez pas casser le place comme soit
emportée contre alphonse alors votre
père ne leur ait pas de loyer et
maintenant pour elle tandis que puis on
aurait de la pluie à volonté allez vous
coucher je vous ai assez vu et le
lendemain il faisait toujours beau et
effrayant j'ai les réviser les primes
allemand laisse moi y aller je vais
profiter de ce qu'elles sont en chemise
de nuit pour leur flanquer une fessée
c'est pas ça qui fera pleuvoir non mais
ça me calmera allez debout
il fait de plus en plus beau à vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir je
vais vous expliquer comme je pensais
bien que vous regretteriez jeux plus
tard les explications
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on commence par fait tatouer les jv eu
[Musique]
la semaine suivante il eu un autre
événement ayant eu l'idée de raser sa
barbe et de se faire faire un dentier
l'attend mélina trouva à se marier et à
la habiter le venezuela